(electronic music)
- Welcome to A Conversation With History,
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is
Arlie Russell Hochschild
who is one of the most
influential sociologists
of her generation.
She is the author of nine books,
including The Second Shift, The Time Bomb,
The Managed Heart and the Outsourced Self.
Three of her books have been named
as New York Times notable
books of the year,
and her work appears in 16 languages.
The winner of the Ulysses medal
as well as Guggenheim and Mellon Grants,
she lives in Berkeley, California.
She has been a professor in Berkeley's
Sociology Department since 1971,
and is now a professor
in the graduate school
at Berkeley.
She was recognized by
the American Sociological Association
as one of the most
imaginative and productive
feminist sociologists
in the United States.
As a scholar she has been at the forefront
of research on contemporary
work and family life
for over 30 years.
Arlie's new book is
Strangers In Their Own Land,
Anger and Mourning on the American Right,
a journey to the heart
of our political divide.
Arlie, welcome to our program.
- Thank you very much.
- Where were you born and raised?
- Well, let's see, I was born
in Boston, Massachusetts,
and raised in the suburbs of Washington DC
until I was 12.
And then my dad was in
the Foreign Service,
so I lived in a bunch of countries.
- And looking back, how
do you think your parents
shaped your thinking about the world,
and in your case, more important in a way,
how to deal with people?
- Well, following my dad's career
led me to a lot of different situations
where I didn't speak the language,
I didn't look like other people,
I was wearing the wrong clothes.
I was kind of the outsider, the oddball.
And yet I had social support in that role,
and I think it's why I'm
a sociologist, honestly.
I had to figure it out.
- I have the sense that as a young person
you were at some of
the teas and receptions
and could watch these different people.
- That's right.
I was the little kid passing the peanuts
and kind of watching how
people were interacting,
and people from different worlds,
how they were relating to each other,
the different signal systems.
Yeah, I watched from below, you could say.
- But listening, all the time listening.
Where were you educated?
- I went to Swarthmore
College in Pennsylvania,
and then came out to
Berkeley for my graduate work
in sociology.
- And any particular scholars
influence you greatly
in your choice of sociology as a field?
- Well, yes.
Actually,
as an undergraduate I
had read David Riesman's
The Lonely Crowd, and thought wow.
You get to really do the same thing,
look from underneath,
and look at the logics
that might be hidden in the kind of selves
that we take for granted.
But coming to Berkeley,
this was the best department in the world.
And we had Niel Smelser,
who was my advisor,
and an extraordinary
support to me in my work.
And Erving Goffman.
And there was Reinhardt Bendix.
- So the greatest of the great.
- Yeah, so I thought wow,
this was exactly where I wanna be.
- And what did you do
your dissertation on?
- Well, my dissertation
was on the elderly.
That was before, (laughing)
that seemed like a foreign land, you know.
And it became a book called
The Unexpected Community.
And I went in thinking whoa,
we've had segregation by race,
but this is segregation by
age, and this is a problem.
And I got a job as a
recreation director's assistant
in a low-income housing
project in San Pablo here.
So again, I was sort of starting micro,
having a good look close up,
but asking a larger question of
does this work or not?
And what I discovered is
that the people I talked to
who were generally Oakies and Arkies
who had come out to work in the shipyards
during World War II, extraordinary people.
Many were women who would bake muffins
for three dozen, and then
hand them out to others.
They liked this arrangement.
They had close bonds with their family,
but they liked the community.
And they didn't think they were old.
Why they had a three-piece
band that played for
the old folks in nursing homes.
You know, washboard bass, and very lively.
And at that time there
was a well-known theory
of disengagement, Cumming and Henry.
So my thesis said wait a minute,
this theory of disengagement --
- From your subjects.
- From my subjects, right.
Well the theory said that as you get older
you disengage socially.
But every day I was going to
do participant observation
with a group who were
anything but disengaged.
In fact, living together
they were more engaged
than they had been ten years earlier.
So I was looking at the
sociology of engagement,
and saying that theory
really needs to be modified.
In the last few weeks or months of life
you may disengage, but
all the time before that,
I was seeing a story of
tremendous engagement
and looking at the
circumstances that created it,
fostered it.
- I like to ask my guests
what advice they would give
to students who would like
to prepare for a career
similar to that of my guest.
Now what do you see as
the skills and temperament
involved in the work of a
sociologist such as yourself?
- Oh wow.
I think, first of all,
it's good to have
earlier been a little bit
estranged from your circumstances.
Strange thing to say,
but to have been the oddball,
to have been the outsider.
And I think sociology's
discipline isn't something
people fall into, I think
they're attracted to it
because they've been
exposed to that experience
and it makes them curious
about membership in a group.
So if you've got that, it's
a good sign, not a bad sign.
And then I think your capacity,
well as for any discipline,
to be really curious.
To relax about yourself,
to be really curious
about the issue or problem
you've taken to study.
To be able to take your
own alarm system off
and listen to people that
you know disagree with you.
That's a very important skill.
And the other thing I'd says is look,
you will be told how to do
things in graduate school,
and some of the things
you're gonna have to unlearn.
Don't take it quite as written in stone.
- What about temperament?
The temperament of someone who wants
to go in to sociology?
You've already partly
answered that question.
But in others words, in
the end it takes courage
to be at this boundary,
to be an oddball yourself
in a way, and be looking at things
and trying to find the complexity.
- I'm not sure.
I have friends and colleagues in sociology
that have every kind of temperament.
And some do historical
work, extraordinary,
really insightful historical
work and comparative work.
Some of my friends are studying
the general social survey
and it doesn't call on those skills.
But those of us who learn close up
by studying encounters,
then I think we do need
this kind of temperament.
- You are considered to be a
pioneer in feminist studies
in sociology, and also in
the sociology of emotions.
So you're a pathbreaking scholar.
My next question is about creativity.
What are the factors
that make sociologists
such as yourself creative,
and carve out new paths?
- Wow.
Thank you for the compliment.
I think to experiment,
this'll be paradoxical,
we have to feel safe.
So it is a paradox.
You think of the explorer
as someone who does without
a sense of safety, who stalks
ahead stoically without it.
It's not been my experience.
And what I tell my students
is, get your cocoon.
You know, get your family,
get your best friends,
make a book group, a study group,
get your support system.
Then, with that support,
it won't be so frightening
to reach out, you'll have
someone to report back to.
And then, I actually think that the world
draws us into it, if you let it.
Like people have asked me,
with regard to the research I did
for Strangers In Their Own Land,
oh my goodness, how
did you, they must have
felt like you came from Mars
and been unfriendly to you,
and how did you get going with them?
Well not at all, that
wasn't my experience.
I would say hi, I'm Arlie Hochschild,
the one with the
unpronounceable last name,
and I probably look like
Mary Poppins to you,
(laughing) I come from
Berkeley California,
I teach in the Sociology Department,
and I live in a bubble,
a very different one,
but I've been really concerned
about how divided our country has become.
And then I would see a nodded head,
yeah we're worried about that too.
And so I'm here really to understand
people that live in your bubble,
and see if there aren't
some common threads here,
and common ground that
we're not looking at.
So I began like that,
and they would say yes.
Well people where you come from
think we're backward,
and hicks and southern
and uneducated, so you set them straight,
yes come on.
- So you call in your
book the empathy wall,
climbing that wall to see
what's on the other side.
But it sounds to me like there's a lot of
diplomacy involved, diplomatic skills,
I won't say diplomacy, because
I think you're being honest,
diplomats aren't always honest.
But there are skills involved.
- Skills.
Yes I think there are,
and the main skill I think
involved in really getting to know
and listening closely
and feeling comfortable listening closely
to people who are saying things
that you have strong feelings about,
and commitments behind those feelings,
the main thing is to be able
to take your alarm system
off for a period of time,
and be honest about it.
I'll give you example.
There was one woman I met in
doing research for Strangers,
at the Republican Women
for Southwest Louisiana.
She was the wife of a
Pentecostal minister,
big mega church.
And she was a wonderful gospel singer.
And she said, oh I love Rush Limbaugh,
the very conservative radio host.
And I thought to myself privately,
oh dear dear, whoa.
And then I thought, no I
wanna understand her love.
So I said, could I speak with you?
So we did, next day we met for sweet tea.
And she's telling me I love Rush Limbaugh
because he really gives
it to those feminazis.
I thought I hope she hasn't
read The Second Shift.
And those environmental wackos.
And so I'm listening to her,
and she then says to me,
has it been hard to listen?
Because I know, you've told me,
that you don't agree with what I'm saying.
And I told her, you know
actually not at all.
Because I'm not here to tell you about me,
I'm here to learn.
And you are doing me a
bigger favor than you know.
I am so grateful that you're letting me in
to your way of thinking and
sharing your life with me.
And then, she said yes, I do that too.
With my parishioners, with my kids,
I don't always have to start with me.
So then we have that in common.
So then, okay let's start
there, we both do that.
And then I really began to learn something
because then she said,
Rush Limbaugh feels like my
Braveheart, she called him,
because she protects me
from the liberal epithets
of you racist, homophobic, sexist,
fat redneck,
that she felt the liberals
were lobbing at her.
I didn't know that people felt that way,
that that was what they
got from listening to him.
So I learned a lot only after
sharing this thing with her.
So it went like that.
- So you are considered a pioneer
in what is called the
sociology of emotions.
And I read a little about that.
And you're, in a way,
looking for the rules
that help people define the emotions
that are permitted in different settings
and different contexts.
So this was a powerful background
in helping you on this journey
that you've already begun describing.
- And there's one other ingredient,
if I look back at myself, what
am I putting together here?
I think I'm putting together
my early experiences
in being the oddball in
these different countries.
And I suppose watching
my father the diplomat.
But I had a brother who
was a psychoanalyst.
And he gave me the feeling, older brother,
of you know,
all of the covert patterns
and intrapsychic, unconscious
processes that go on.
I was fascinated by that.
And yet it felt too locked
into an intrapsychic system,
it didn't have the sociology of it,
that I'd been exposed to as a kid,
look at all these different groups.
So this set of rules applies differently
to these different groups.
And I think I went to
sociology to get some tools
for how to put these two things together.
- Interesting.
So this book,
Strangers In Their Own Land,
is a departure for you,
in the sense not of your methodology
and the things that we're talking about
in terms of the sociology of emotions,
but rather in terms of the subject matter.
And I think the dates are very important.
So the book is published in 2016,
and you started the work on this book
by going to Louisiana five years before.
So why did you choose this subject
and why did you choose Louisiana?
- Well I chose this subject because
I was worried that there
was rumbling on the right,
that there was a growth of it.
And that it stood, and I
felt that it would grow,
I had that intuition about it.
I'm not the only one,
something was going on and
I didn't understand it.
But why Louisiana?
Well I figured, I'm in a bubble
here in Berkeley California,
let me find an equal and opposite bubble
that's as far right as
sociology Berkeley California is left.
And where would that be,
that would be in the South.
And I looked at the number of whites
who voted for Barack Obama in 2012.
And in the whole region of
the South, it was a third.
But in Louisiana and Mississippi,
Louisiana it was just 14%.
So that's the super-South,
that's where I wanna go.
And it was, surveys showed,
virtually half of the
population said it agreed
with the tenets of the Tea Party.
That was five years ago, 2011.
And so I thought okay, this was perfect.
So who do I want? I want
whites, I want religious people,
and where in Louisiana?
Well,
I was interested in the
petrochemical industry.
- And pollution.
Because pollution became
the keyhole issue for me.
Because I started, with this
open mind, alarm system off,
but with the a question,
the red state paradox.
How can it be that in the whole country
it's the poorest states,
it's the states with the worst schools,
the worst medical care, the
most disrupted families,
the highest number of road accidents,
the worst pollution, and
the lowest life expectancy
are also the states that get more money
from the federal government in aid
than they give to it in tax dollars,
and revile the federal government.
Well, wait a minute,
if you have a problem,
don't you want some help with it?
So that was the red state paradox.
And I discovered that Louisiana
was an exaggerated version of that,
as the second poorest state.
44% of the state budget came
from the federal government,
overwhelming conservative,
and in the end very pro-Trump.
So that was an exaggerated version
of this red state paradox.
And then I began to smell the air,
and look at everybody
who had water bottles.
And sometimes when I
drove over the I10 bridge
in Lake Charles to West Lake,
there's this vast, almost industrial city,
my eyes would begin to sting.
And people lived here, gee.
So then I looked and found it was
one of the most polluted
spots on the earth.
And the people did not believe
in regulating polluters.
So I thought, let me focus here.
- So what I'm hearing you say suggests
that as a matter of choice you pick
the perfect petri dish
to find groups of people who
clearly were being driven
by something other than
the reality, the facts,
and seem to be drawing
on their emotions, basically.
Seemed to be feeling something
that was inconsistent
with what a Berkeley
scholar or Berkeley denizens
would conclude based on the facts
and perceptions of the facts.
- I would put it differently.
They were acting according to
what they saw as the facts.
They had different priorities,
that their facts loomed large,
and my facts didn't loom large.
So this was self-interest as they saw it.
It wasn't just emotions floating free
from facts as they saw them.
So this red state paradox, I tried it out.
One guy, who begins the book, Mike Schapp,
we were out fishing, and I thought,
well this is a good place for
me to just put it out there,
what about this red state paradox?
And he said, well we're
embarrassed about it,
we don't like being the
second poorest state,
but that's why we want an economy.
And this other thing is more
important than that paradox.
So you liberals come in and
you focus on this paradox,
and you think we're crazy.
No no, we know it's there,
but it's trumped by this other thing
that I came to call the deep story.
- The deep story.
So the deep story, tell
us what a deep story is,
and then what the deep
story of Louisiana is.
- Yeah.
A deep story is
a story about some salient situation
that feels true.
You take facts out of the deep story,
you strip moral precepts
out of the deep story,
it's just what feels true to you.
And it is, you get to feelings by a story,
that is with what T.S. Eliot would call
the objective correlatives to feelings.
What has to seem true
to you to feel angry,
to feel grief, to feel despair.
So I was looking for the
objective correlatives
to what felt true if you
stripped away the feeling rules
as I call them in my work.
And,
their deep story
is that, it can be told
in almost a dreamlike way,
through a metaphor,
that you're standing in
line, as in a pilgrimage,
facing up a hill.
At the top of the hill
is the American dream,
and your feet are facing it.
And you feel you really
deserve that dream,
you have worked hard,
you've played by the rules,
but the line isn't moving.
People haven't had a raise in two decades,
the ones I interviewed.
So you're waiting in line,
and the prize is there,
you're getting on in years,
now's the time for the reward.
And then you see some line-cutters,
and you think well wait
a minute, it's not fair.
And who are they, they
are blacks and women
who through federally-mandated
affirmative action programs
are finally being given access
to jobs and opportunities
that had been reserved for whites and men.
And then immigrants and
refugees and others.
And then another moment of
this right-wing deep story,
the leader who should be
impartially supervising this line
seems to be waving to the line-cutters.
And who is that, that's Barack Obama.
And then people would say,
oh he must be a line-cutter too.
How did he get, how did his mother pay for
a Harvard education?
Must be something fishy.
I heard that time and time again.
Questioning how he could have done this,
and envy in it.
We misunderstand racial feeling.
It's not just fear of, you know,
the thug who will come to the door.
No no, this is envy,
he's so well-spoken, he's so intelligent,
he's gone to Harvard and Columbia, wow.
So anyway,
that alliance makes them feel cut out.
They've waited in line,
they are forgotten,
this is not their land.
And then add to that
that the land they're on
in fact is polluted, it is not their land.
It's been polluted by industry,
public waters aren't
public waters anymore.
And that leads to a
kind of an estrangement,
and a looking around for rescue.
So that was the deep story.
I got to it by listening for a long time,
making up that story, and
then going back to my people
and trying again.
How does this sit with you?
Yeah, people said, I live your metaphor,
how did you read my mind?
And then some people would say,
no no, the end, we move
over to another line,
or secede from the country, basically.
Or, no you've left out
that we line-waiters
are paying through our
taxes for the line-cutters,
and that's not fair.
So they elaborated the story.
But basically, it made sense to them.
So it's not that they're
irrational, in one sense,
it's that we have to
understand how the world looks,
the standpoint that people
on the right are taking.
And by the way, I think all of us,
wherever we land on
the political spectrum,
have a deep story.
- So, what's interesting about this is,
in your book you go through
the many factors at work
from history, the nature of
the South's political culture,
where the dominating and the dominated,
related to slavery and
the white working class
not looking and comparing
themselves to the top,
because they always believed
they could rise to that level,
but looking down and saying,
well we're better than the blacks.
- Or, oh my God, let
that not happen to us.
- So this is kind of built
in to the political culture
of the South.
And the left comes along after the 60s
and emphasizes identity, and
it's important to politics.
So the notion of the identity
of a black, of a woman,
of a gay person, is important,
and that is thrust at these people,
and it helps push them toward the emphasis
on a white identity.
So there's a white identity,
their identity as a white person.
So a lot is going on, there's
a lot of complexity here.
But you, in talking to individuals,
are able to conceptualize this deep story
that in a way pulls it all together.
Is that fair?
- Well thank you.
You know,
of course the civil rights movement
was focusing on rights, not
so much identity but rights.
- That came later, the identity politics.
- The identity politics came later.
But yeah, the focus was on rights,
which were constitutional and fundamental,
but not implemented in the South.
And from their, and of
course my husband and I
were civil rights workers,
actually at Vicksburg, Mississippi, 1964,
freedom summer.
So that was about rights.
But from the point of view of whites
whose ancestors were in
the 1860s poor farmers,
they were not slave
owners, but they fought,
they were the cannon fodder.
And in fact, as Cash in The
Mind Of The South makes clear,
poor whites were
shoved off of the good land,
they were put back in the
swamps and the hinterlands,
and their labor wasn't needed
because of slave labor.
So they could grow corn,
but even the forests didn't
provide hunting for them
because that became off limits.
So anyway, the whites have
historically been marginalized,
they've historically kind of grown up
in a culture that Church is pointing out
didn't have any tradition
of a public square,
and of public goods, of a public commons,
of great schools and museums.
That wasn't part of the
plantation tradition.
And their only way out
would be to identify up,
and distance themselves
from the abject slave.
So that's the culture
that they've inherited,
and I think that one
has to acknowledge that
and begin a whole series of
conversations about that.
Starting with the idea of human rights.
- So the deep story
is a conceptual construct
that is more than a concept,
because when you run this by
the people they agree with it.
But it fits into a context,
both in terms of history,
in terms of institutions,
you look at the press,
you look at the government in Louisiana,
and what is bizarre is the
people who you're interviewing
are people who hunt,
who love the outdoors.
So they're almost Californian
in their appreciation
of their surroundings,
and so they are watching
the erosion of the natural beauty.
Now something comes up in the story
when you talk to the general who commanded
the saving of New Orleans.
And he talks about the importance of jobs.
So what the oil companies
and the polluting industries
offer for jobs.
And these people see jobs, jobs jobs jobs,
as a way to transcend
what is happening to them,
and give them honor and
security and other things.
And that really comes out in your book,
it's very interesting.
- Yes, and you're speaking
of General Russell Honore
who was an absolutely
extraordinary figure,
and with brilliant mediation skills.
I followed him around just
to listen to how he talked.
And what he said
is that there's just enough
to the rhetoric of jobs jobs jobs,
to make them swallow a
psychological program.
And I looked at the
statistics in Louisiana,
actually only 15% of jobs
have anything to do with oil.
These are highly-automated plants,
and there are very few
permanent jobs in those plants.
And even then, they import
Filipino pipefitters,
for example, who are cheaper.
So most jobs are outside of oil.
And in fact, what could
be booming industries,
tourism, it's a beautiful state,
could be an extraordinary
tourism industry.
But oil has kind of wrecked
that by polluting the place.
And restaurants and fishing,
this is hurt by oil too.
So we've gone, in Louisiana,
from a plantation system,
you know used to be cotton, now it's oil.
And there is a political culture
that is oriented to a
dominant economic interest.
And the people I came to know in Louisiana
were used to a state that
did the bidding of industry.
It's what we call a captured state.
And so I came to understand
why they hated the government.
Because they thought
the federal government
is just a bigger, badder
version of the state government,
and our state government isn't helping us.
And they got that idea by looking
at Louisiana Department
of Environmental Quality,
which gave out permits
to pollute very easily,
and didn't protect the people.
So in a way, industry
outsourced the moral dirty work
to the states.
So people thought, I'm paying the salary
of people who aren't protecting me,
why am I paying for that,
the state isn't working.
But oh the industry is
talking jobs jobs jobs,
and by the way it's giving money
to the Audubon Society,
to Louisiana State
University football uniforms.
And that's money that
actually is public money,
because under Governor Jindal,
$1.5 billion went as incentive money
to the petro industry,
and with that money they
could give out gifts.
So you can see, actually this
is the sociology of emotions,
that you can see industry
has been brilliant
at getting itself loved, branding,
and getting the state hated.
And so it wasn't a mystery,
it wasn't irrational
from their point of view
to take a jaundiced view of the state.
- Let's go back to the
timeline of this book,
because you were making these discoveries,
forming this conceptual
way of looking at it,
before Trump was a candidate,
most of this work was done.
You published in 2016,
I guess then he announces his candidacy.
You talk a little about Trump,
and going to a Trump rally,
and you say Trump is
an emotions candidate.
So having laid out for us
the landscape of emotions
in the deep hard right,
you see a resonance there.
- Oh I do.
I think we can talk about
people who have, who
pursue an emotional logic.
In other words, what
they do to evoke emotion
is not illogical.
It can serve an important
purpose, it can be logical.
And I think that's the way
to understand our president.
For example,
my interpretation of a recent event
would be this:
the leader of North Korea
has said he's got this nuclear bomb
and could bomb us,
and Trump has taunted him,
really escalating this rhetoric.
And meanwhile, Rex Tillerson,
the Secretary of State,
has said well we're beginning talks,
and Trump says no, he's
wasting his breath, no talks.
And you think the man's irrational.
This makes no sense, this
is his Secretary of State.
Either he's not in any
communication with him,
or maybe there are two
channels of communication,
people are confused, it seems irrational.
Well yes, on the one hand,
this is very dangerous.
But on the other hand,
is he trying to just keep us all anxious?
Just to keep everybody in doubt
as to what's gonna happen,
oriented towards him as
the author of our future,
and kind of hyping up.
Is that what he intends, and
what purpose does that fulfill?
I think that's the way we need to think.
And that any politician of course
is aware of heightened symbols
and emotional magnetism,
and plays to those symbols,
and certainly we have a man
who's doing this expertly.
But that's, I think, the
way we need to think.
We need to look for emotional logics,
and stop trying to look for patterns
of a more rational sort.
- And what's interesting is that
your book gives us the landscape,
the topography of the far right,
and the right's, emotional landscape,
I guess we would call it.
And once you know that,
then you're able, one is
able, the reader is able,
to look at Trump differently.
Not necessarily like him,
so then the whole business of
dismantling the Obama state,
the whole business of making cultural war
to arouse emotions against the NFL,
begins to represent a political logic
that comes from an understanding
of the emotional system.
- Exactly, exactly.
On some of the Facebooks
after that NFL event,
I saw pictures of a,
this is on the Facebook pages
of some of the people that I write about,
a picture on one hand of
a group of white soldiers,
and underneath it, serving
our country, $30,000 a year.
And then NFL, none of
them served our country,
and multimillionaires, 40
million a year and so on.
Envy.
Gosh, line-cutter, that's what it goes to.
- So if we call the
people you study rednecks,
and boobs or whatever,
then we deny ourselves an understanding
of their emotional system.
And understanding their emotional system
is key to understand what Trump is up to,
basically, and who he's appealing to.
- Yes, that's right, that's right.
And understanding where
the conversation is.
It's not that where I was
in southwest Louisiana,
it wasn't this that or the
other Tea Party Trump lover,
everybody, the public conversation,
was very much agreed upon.
And it made me feel that
on the question of race,
the kinds of issues that came
up routinely in the 1960s
on the coasts, kind of was
put on stop in the South.
I'll give you an example.
One man I was talking with
said well you know I'm a reformed bigot.
And I said, well what's a bigot?
Well, a bigot is someone who hates blacks,
I never hated blacks, or used the N-word,
but now I did used to use the N-word,
they did, I did too.
But now it offends me,
someone uses that word on
my Facebook, unfriend them.
So reformed bigot.
And I asked him, so in
a very narrow definition
of what a bigot was, or what racism,
didn't have any notion of
a system, something larger.
And I asked him, what was it like
when your high school was integrated?
Donelsonville High,
this is on what we now call Cancer Alley
in the lower loops of the Mississippi.
And he said well,
in my freshman year there
were two blacks in my class,
and by my senior year half
the class were blacks.
And we were out fishing.
And I asked him,
so did you make any new friends?
And there was a long pause.
And he said,
you're making me think.
And I thought, I'm making you think?
This is something you
haven't thought before,
these could be new friends?
And I felt like the conversation
that was going on on the
coast was really on pause.
And there are things
that just haven't been
considered and discussed in a respectful,
mind-changing way.
Only in a attack-defend
confrontational way.
And there's a job to be done.
Speaking of the teacher.
- We're coming to the end of our program,
and there's just so much to cover.
So everybody has to just
go out and read the book,
because we can't cover everything.
But one really final
question, which is this.
In a way you were the liberal community's
unappointed secret envoy
to the heart of Louisiana.
And what comes to mind
is President Roosevelt
sending Harry Hopkins to Russia.
So I guess the question
is, beyond the book,
what is the message, in a nutshell,
about how the liberal community should
turn your insights into action
that might bring the country together?
- Wonderful question.
And incidentally, there
were liberals of course
in Louisiana doing wonderful work.
They were in a minority, but
they were certainly present.
There is something
called a bridge movement.
And if you were to Google
the Bridge Alliance,
you would find it's an umbrella group
describing some 70, it's now 80,
different grassroots organizations
with names like Hi From The Other Side,
or Living Room Conversations.
Groups that are trying
to bridge the divide.
Not that people are gonna
morph into each other,
and we're not talking about that.
But in search of particular issues
on which there can be common ground.
And right here at Berkeley
there is Berkeley Bridge.
I'm in touch with some fantastic students
that are doing this.
We need to get debates going.
The whole Berkeley culture
needs to be enriched
so that talking across
this divide isn't scary,
isn't repugnant, isn't attack-defend,
but it's really exploring ideas.
And I think this can be
done in a lot of ways,
theater, satire, lots of different ways.
I think that culture on the UC campus
has become atrophied,
and I think we need to
beef it up, enrich it.
And the Bridge Movement
is really all about that.
I found a lot of crossover on such issues
as reducing prison populations,
getting money out of politics.
In fact, reducing pollution.
Renewable energy.
There's something called
the Green Tea Movement,
where Tea Party people are
embracing solar and so on.
Protecting children.
There's actually
quite a lot we could agree on.
Including being proud of
America, quite basically.
We may mean different
things about being American,
and patriotism, but we need to
learn to stretch our symbols,
not to step over and deride them,
but to learn how to stretch them,
how to apply a value to circumstances
that the person may
not have thought about.
You say you're a patriot, great,
so does that mean sacrificing,
willingness to sacrifice for your country?
That's what most people I talked to
felt about the flag and the constitution,
or does it also mean
defending the free press?
So symbol stretches.
- I have one final question,
and I'm looking for a brief answer.
Is there something that
Trump is doing as president
that would alienate the
people that you observed?
- They're sticking with
him, they're loyal.
They're not excited about him anymore,
but they don't see anything else for them.
I started with a red state paradox,
but I end with a blue state paradox.
How could it be that the Democratic Party,
the party of the working man and woman
isn't appealing to these
working men and women?
That's the work that needs to be done.
- Well on that note, Arlie,
I can't recommend your book enough
for people on the left
side of the spectrum
to become informed about the right side.
So thank you very much
for coming on our program,
and thank you very much
for writing this book.
- Thank you very much, honored to be here.
- And thank you very much
for joining us for this
Conversation With History.
(electronic music)